I’m working on a little project right now
and I need your help! All the details are
on a YouTube post I’m linking, but basically
I’m building a deck around an unknown event
card created for me using feedback from both my
in-person opponents and my online audience. If
you want to suggest cards that could go in the
deck, you can do that under the YouTube post,
and if you want to guarantee an on-color
card going in the deck, you can send it
to my PO Box address in the description. With
that said, let’s get to garbage magic cards.
Let’s say you have a type of card that you
want to see in a lot of games with a given
deck—a mana rock, a one-mana creature that gains
life, or something else. If that’s the case,
it can be helpful to run some calculations
on how often you’ll draw it, either by using
a hypergeometric calculator like the one on my
website or by referencing the built in calculators
that a deckbuilding website like Archidekt might
have. At this point, a lot of players are aware of
these sorts of tools, but what they might not be
aware of is that you can do the opposite—you can
check how often you won’t draw cards that suck.
And, just as you could use this to decide how many
of a desirable card type to add, you can also
do the same deciding how few of an undesirable
card type to add. Because it might actually
be okay to have some bad cards in your deck.
But hold on, let’s take a step back here. What
do I mean when I say bad card, and why would
I want to run any of these? Starting with that
first question, the card in question could truly
be a bad card. My Radha Heir to Keld deck has a
single, permanent “funny seven drop” deck slot.
It was occupied by Panglacial Wurm in the past,
and it’s currently occupied by Tyrant of Discord,
with both of these being not very good creatures.
However, the meaning of bad card could also be a
bit more complicated, being a card that is
either situational or bad without certain
other cards to support it. As one example,
in three different grindy decks I play,
there’s a card present that is there entirely for
the purpose of lifegain. These cards are pretty
worthless outside of this task, but they do an
admirable job in a mid-to-late-game situation
where my life total is in a state of peril.
As another example, in my bracket two deck
I run a couple artifact creatures that untap
things. These cards on their own are terrible,
but paired with other cards they can be pretty
powerful, and Voltaic Construct is technically
part of a convoluted infinite combo the deck
can assemble. As a final example, protection
spells fit both of these two criteria as cards
that aren’t useful until you’re doing something
worth protecting, and whose usefulness isn’t
realized until an opponent tries to disrupt you.
So this is what I mean when I say “bad
cards”—cards that frequently don’t feel very good
to draw for one reason or another, particularly
in the early game. But, why does the category
I’m constructing treat these different types of
card as the same, and if they’re “bad” in some
sense then why run them in the first place? The
answer is that I think of a lot of commander decks
as having two very distinct phases: pre-engine,
and post-engine. In the early phases of a game,
you only have access to a very small number
of cards, and a lot of decks gain access to
additional cards through the synergies between
these early cards. This could take a lot of forms:
maybe you have a Wall of Omens and a
Teleportation Circle. Maybe you follow up
your Caustic Bronco with an Isshin. Maybe you
curve Thran Dynamo into a Pull from Tomorrow.
Maybe you just play a standalone draw engine
like an Esper Sentinel or a Phyrexian Arena,
or even a series of one-off spells like Night’s
Whisper and Harmonize. Regardless, you’re using
stuff from your more limited early game card pool
to help your deck reach a state where it’s online,
and has access to a much wider range
of the different tools within it. And,
there are actually a lot of things that can
help with this. Card draw, tutors, filtering,
ramp, or synergy pieces that assist with any of
these last four things—all of these can help you
build up to a point where you’re more flush with
resources. Removal and defensive cards can also
help with this, since they buy you time to get
that engine up and going. Different cards will
help different amounts with this, but quite a
lot of cards will assist at least a little bit.
All of this is well and good, but you still
might be wondering why exactly I’m drawing
this pre-engine and post-engine distinction. The
answer to that is that once you’re cycling through
a more significant amount of your deck per turn,
whether or not each individual card is useful in
a wide variety of situations starts to become a
lot less important. If I draw five cards and one
of them isn’t that useful to me right now, that’s
okay! I still drew four other cards. This is also
the point in the game where you’re going to
start discarding to hand size if you don’t
have a Reliquary Tower effect, and this is one of
my favorite points in a game to be in. Getting to
purge the trash for the first time in a game and
sculpt a hand of seven beautiful, situationally
applicable cards? Delicious. As a slight tangent,
this sort of reasoning is also why I like a type
of budget dual land that a lot of other people
seem to dislike: the humble fast-land. A land
that enters tapped if you control three or more
other lands might seem kinda bad in theory—in
the average bracket 3 commander game you’re
hopefully making at least seven land drops,
so in less than half of land drops will this land
enter untapped. However, turn four and beyond is
also a point in the game at which a lot of decks
will be drawing or looting or otherwise filtering,
enabling them to find their way to a variety
of different lands with relative ease. The
first three turns of the game are the ones where
you’re going to be hardest pressed to have a land
that both enters untapped and gives the colors you
need, and fast-lands fill in this exact profile.
So, if your deck is one that rounds a corner and
starts to see a lot more cardboard at some point,
having a somewhat subpar or situational card is a
lot less of a problem from that point onward. But
what does this mean for the early game? Well,
as I suggested earlier, you can do a bit of
math to see how likely it is for your gameplan
to get online. One option here is to separate
your nonland cards into three buckets. Bucket 1
is high quality draw and filtering, stuff that
finds you to what you need to succeed quickly and
easily. Bucket 2 is stuff that’s basically useless
for getting your deck online—hyper-situational
cards, protection spells, later game tech pieces,
finishers, and stuff that’s just kinda bad
you’re including for shits and giggles,
as is your god-given right. Bucket 3 is all the
other stuff outside of these two categories: ramp,
removal, somewhat narrower draw, and sometimes
applicable tech pieces. Now, you perform two
different checks here. For one, how likely is
it for you to draw one of your bucket 1 cards,
your premium-quality enablers? The larger
this number is, the better, but there are
certainly reasons this number could be lower
for some decks. Question two is how likely is
it for you to draw one of your bucket 2 cards
that helps you very little in the early game,
and possibly more importantly, how likely
is it for you to draw multiple of these? If
you’re running five or so hyper-situational
cards, the odds of drawing more than one of
these is quite low. By contrast, if that number
starts creeping into the double digits, you might
have games where you draw an Overwhelming
Stampede and a Heroic Intervention in your
first ten cards of the game, a Fervor and a Full
Throttle, a Clever Concealment and a Storm Herd.
You can almost think about all of these bucket
2 “bad cards” as blank for the purposes of your
early game. Having a lot of these is generally
going to slow your timeline for getting off
the ground and lead to more stallouts, but you
can counterbalance this tendency with a greater
amount of Bucket 1 cards—high quality draw and
filtering. Hitting a string of situational cards
you won’t want until later in the game can be a
problem, but it might not be if you have a lot
of filtering and draw and tutors at the ready
to cut you through this dead zone of your deck.
So, how much trash is it okay to put in your
deck? I mean, don’t let me stop you from living
your best life, especially if you’re more in
bracket 2 territory, but the realistic answer
is that it depends on what the rest of your
deck is doing. If we’re talking about some
terrible pet cards that you would literally die
for, take a look at how many other cards you’re
running that you’d be kinda bummed to draw
before turn 5. If that number is very low,
you’re probably okay to add some garbage to your
deck! Treat this as your reward for being such
a responsible deckbuilder in other ways. If that
number is stretching into double digits territory,
you’ll want to be a bit more careful. How
much general-purpose draw and filtering are
you running?How broadly useful is your commander
for generating resources and helping your deck get
going? My deck with the highest number of bucket
2 cards is my Meria voltron deck, with a ton of
protection as well as equipments that give extra
damage and evasion. With any other commander,
this deck’s ratios would make no sense at all
and it would flail around doing nothing most
of the time. However, because Meria is a sweet
draw engine and one of the best mana producers
in the game, and because my deck is pretty decent
at protecting her, it ends up working out most of
the time. Likewise, it’s not a coincidence that
my one bracket 3 deck where I allow myself to
indulge in significantly more janky pet cards is
also one where I have a mana dork commander and
a massive pile of four cost ramp spells and 6-7
cost bombs that I’m pretty much always happy to
draw. Craft the foundation of your deck in a
way that’s maximally consistent and flexible,
and the amount of room to sprinkle garbage
into that bad boy might just surprise you.
Thanks for watching! Make sure to check out
the YouTube post in the description if you
want to contribute to that, and another thing
you can check out is fantastic products from
Dragonshield. I’m a longtime enjoyer of their
dual matte sleeves, with my Radha deck still
going strong in the same set of peach sleeves
thousands of shuffles in. Sleeves that have
been used that heavily have a really interesting
shuffle feel to them, but that’s not something
you’ll ever get to experience with most other
brands. Dragonshield has also been expanding out
into deckboxes and other storage methods, which
I’m also a fan of—the deckboxes are elegant and
effective. Get 5% off your order at the link
in the description, and you’ll be helping the
channel in the process. If you want to support
the channel more directly, you can sign up for
my Patreon or a YouTube membership. I’m in the
process of moving right now, which is exciting in
some ways but also expensive, so any extra dough
to throw at gas and craigslist furniture is much
appreciated! A big thanks to current Patrons
and YouTube members for their ongoing support.